sri lanka's interim government has
reimposed a curfew a day after angry
crowds stormed government buildings the
prime minister who is now acting
president has ordered security forces to
restore calm
protesters have agreed to leave
government buildings as people still
wait for the official resignation of
president gotabaya rajapaksa he fled the
country while it is going through a
devastating economic crisis
and we are now joined by oliver meyer
who is the south asia correspondent for
german public broadcaster aid he is in
colomba colombo the sri lankan capital
oliver how's the situation in the
capital right now it looks quite
peaceful
yeah well it's certainly way more calm
today um before there was a hectic day
yesterday uh people were protesting in
front of the office of the prime
minister
the police used tear gas yesterday
evening we were at the parliament also
lots of tear gas coming from the police
lots of wounded people and today i just
talked to protesters they said it's uh
like the quiet before the storm i mean
the situation is still that the
president hasn't really resigned the
prime minister has taken over as an
acting president and people are still
very very mad and they demand a
resignation right away that's what they
want and they say they have to gather
their strength now for the next upcoming
demonstration if the president and the
prime minister don't resign in the
upcoming days
well the prime minister said that he
will resign so what's the holdup
where is the president now and when can
we expect the formal resignation
[Music]
yeah lots of questions where i don't
have definite answers to the fact is
that president gotta gotta buy a richard
paxa flew to the maldives yesterday
which is not his final destination as
sources say his final destinations may
either be singapore or saudi arabia
that's probably where he's heading to
and he said before he hasn't reached his
final destination he will not resign and
that's what makes protesters so angry
and
pretty much the same as for prime
minister rani vikram singh
he said he's going to resign when a new
government is being built and that's
probably going to be in next wednesday
but
it's also a thing that people are not
very sure about here and he also might
be running as a president as well which
people do not want at all
the people want to see both gotabaya
rajapaksa
right away actually
now there are shortages of fuel food and
medicine among other necessities how are
ordinary sri lankans coping
very very tough for all of these people
we talked to many of these people for
example just a few days ago we talked to
a guy who has been standing with us tuk
tuk in front of a line of a fuel station
for seven days and seven nights he
hasn't really left the queue slept in
his tuk tuk and it's really rough for
him and his family because his family is
home his wife is sick he can hardly
provide any medicine he has no fuel to
drive her to the hospital and everyone
is just pretty much struggling to
survive they cannot buy food because
food has gotten really expensive
medicine is not their fuel as i already
mentioned is not there so pretty much
everyone especially the poorest are
really struggling right now in this
country
oliver meyer there reporting from
colombo thank you very much oliver
now sri lanka is descending into chaos
and parliament has been unable to enact
reforms i'm now joined by harini amara
surya a parliamentarian for the national
people's power party can i ask you as an
opposition politician are you powerless
to change this situation at all
uh no we hope not tomorrow parliament is
convened and when parliament is convened
we hope to
move ahead with the appointment of uh
a president
as as agreed at the party leaders
meeting that was convened by the speaker
of the parliament uh several days ago
that on the 20th of this month a
parliament will
elect a new president
currently there is some uh confusion
as to the status of the acting president
because whether how legal that
appointment has been because there is no
official communication from gojabe
rajapaksa who as you know uh left the
country hurriedly and whose whereabouts
ever since uh have been uh unclear
do you think that you as as opposition
have the support of the people on the
street
i think as the opposition the people of
on the street expect us to do a
particular task and that is to ensure
that
uh an interim government is appointed
and that parliament is dissolved as soon
as possible so that fresh elections can
be held
we have been arguing and protesters
outside have also been saying this that
parliament has also lost its legitimacy
now
and that uh what do you say to them
are the other protesters right there has
parliament lost its legitimacy
yes one of the demands of the part of
the protest has been for uh against the
parliament as well because the
parliament as it's currently constituted
uh has a two-thirds majority from the
president's party which has made it
really difficult uh to push through any
kinds of reforms that people have been
demanding and as a result uh there's a
huge sort of trust deficit between uh
the parliament and and uh
the people outside especially the
protesters
uh and and we've been arguing for a
while that this whole crisis
uh the economic crisis has been
precipitated by a deep political crisis
which also needs to be addressed or
which needs to be addressed in in order
to ensure some kind of stability
and for that we are we are asking for a
for a fresh election
okay but are you sure you mentioned a
trust deficit uh between the public uh
and parliament but can you promise any
real change for the country if the
opposition comes to power
well
the the question is that if if there is
an election the people will then select
a party and a set of representatives of
their choice and there will be a period
that will be given to that new
government to that new administration to
to
to make the kinds of interventions or to
bring about the necessary reforms
uh
so that that building of confidence and
that and that um trust
that that will come with a new
government we think is essential we are
not we are not predicting who that new
government is will be but we think that
of election will give a fresh start
uh for a government and a and a new
beginning for for for the people also to
be able to move forward with some kind
of reforms
harini amara surya there parliamentarian
from sri lanka thank you very much for
your time